calculate the sum of all positive
divisors of 27,000 the easiest thing
that I can think of doing is first take
the prime factorization of 27,000 and
then that'll help us kind of structure
our thought of what all of the different
divisors of 27,000 would have to look
like so 27,000 27,000 is the same thing
as 27 times 1,000 which is the same
thing as 3 to the third times 10 to the
third and 10 is of course the same thing
as 2 times 5 so this is the same thing
as 2 times 5 to the third or so same
thing as 2 to the third times 5 to the
3rd so 27,000 27,000 is equal to 2 to
the third times 3 to the third times 5
to the third so any divisor of 27,000 is
going to have to be made up of the
product of up to three twos up to three
threes and up to 3/5 so let's try to
look at all the combinations and think
of a fast way of summing them so let's
just say it has no fives in it it has no
fives in the divisor so if it has no
fives then it can have up to three up to
three twos so let's say it has zero twos
so I'm just going to take the powers of
two so if it has zero to s then we'll
put a 1 here if it has two twos and it
has to be just little by 4 if it has
three twos it's going to be divisible by
8 when I say three twos I mean two times
two times two now let's do it with the
threes let's do it with the threes if
you have oh wait I forgot a power if you
have 0 2 so it means it's just divisible
by 1 from looking at the twos if you
have two - if you have one two it's
divisible by just 2 if you have two twos
you're divisible by 4 and if you have
three twos and what I mean that I'm
saying 2 times 2 times 2 that means
you're divisible by 8 now let's do the
same thing with 3 from the point of view
of 3 if you have no 3s that means at
least you're divisible by 1 if you have
1 3 that means you're divisible by 3 2
threes or 3 times a 3 means you're
divisible by 9 if you have three threes
it means you're divisible by 27 so let's
look at all of the possible combinations
and
for this grid that I'm going to generate
right here we assume that you're not
divisible by five or you're only
divisible by five to the zero power so
what are all the possible numbers here
well you have one times one is one
that's divisible by one and one you have
1 times 3 which is 3 1 times 9 which is
9 1 times 27 which is 27 so these are
all the numbers that are divisible by
that have up to three threes in them
from zero to three threes in them and
they have no twos in them if you throw
another 2 in here you're essentially
going to multiply all of these numbers
by two if you throw another two in here
going to multiply all of these numbers
by two now before I do this because I
want to do this as fast as possible I
could figure out what these numbers are
I could multiply them but instead let's
just take the sum let's just take the
sum here of this row of this first row
that we just did we have 1 plus 3 plus 9
plus 27 3 plus 27 is 31 plus 9 is 10 so
this is going to be 40 now whatever
these numbers are they're all going to
be two times these numbers so the sum is
going to be 80 and the sum over here is
going to be 2 times the previous row
because here we multiplied by 2 here
were multiplying by 4 so it's going to
be 160 and over here we just multiply by
2 again it's going to be 320 or another
way of thinking about it whatever the
sum is here it's going to be 8 times the
sum of the first row and I could just so
you know what I'm doing I could actually
put numbers here this number here would
be 8 24 72 and whatever 8 times 27 have
with that 161 60 Plus 56 so it's 216 but
we don't want to do that we just have to
think about the sums so if you think
about all of the divisors of 27,000 that
are not divisible by 5 so they're only
divisible by 5 to the 0th power I guess
you could say it we have now figured out
there some it's going to be the sum of
all of these rows so if you take 40 plus
80 you have 120 plus 160 is 280 plus 320
is is 600 so this is the situation these
are this is the sum of all of the
combinations of the two
that don't have any fives in them now if
you took the same combination of twos
and threes if you took the same
combination of twos in so these added up
to 600 let me write it over here these
added up to 600 so no fives no fives now
if you did the same exact thing that we
just did here but we just multiplied
everything by five so we then be looking
at all of the combinations that have
this many twos in this many threes and
one five what would happen to this sum
well we would just we would just
multiply it by five so let's multiply
that by five so you multiply 600 by five
you get 30 with two zeroes and so this
is one five one five in the prime
factorization of the divisors one one
five just like that now if I wanted two
fives I can just multiply by five again
so if I multiply by five again I get
fifteen fifteen thousand fifteen
thousand this is two fives - five
another way of thinking about this if I
just multiply this whole every term here
by 25 we're essentially multiplying by
five times five this sum is going to be
600 times 25 which is fifteen thousand
now if I have three fives if I have
three fives then I can just multiply
this by five again five times 15 is 50
plus 25 is 75 so it's 75 75 thousand so
now I know all the sums if I have no
fives the sum of all the divisor is six
hundred I have one five three thousand
so on and so forth so if I want the sum
of everything I just take the sum of
these numbers let me scroll down a
little bit so I get well I have 0 0 then
in the hundreds place I only have a six
and then three plus five plus five is
thirteen is that right yep that's 13 and
then carry the 1 and then I have a 9 so
I have 93 thousand and six hundred so
the sum of all positive divisors of
27,000 93 thousand six hundred
hope you found that entertaining